all right joining us now is glenn
greenwald former constitutional lawyer
and contributing writer and blogger
to salon.com along with david rifkin
former justice department official with
the reagan administration thank you for
being here we're talking about the new
warrantless wiretapping law mr greenwald
why were these what changes were made
and why in your opinion were they
necessary
well i i i think they're not only
unnecessary but actually quite
quite dangerous and and you know the
reason why i think they're dangerous is
the
underlying point here is and always has
been that nobody
is opposed to eavesdropping on
terrorists and al-qaeda everybody wants
strong and aggressive eavesdropping that
is not what this debate is about
the debate is about whether the
president ought to be able to eavesdrop
on the conversations of american
citizens and read our emails
in complete secrecy without any
oversight whatsoever
so that nobody will know if that power
is being abused or whether
he ought to be able to eavesdrop and
engage in surveillance and read emails
only with the oversight of a court in
order to prevent the abuse that for
decades
the american government engaged in when
it was able to eavesdrop in secret
what this law does is it gives the
president of the united states not just
this one but subsequent ones as well
the power to read our emails and listen
in on all of our conversations that
occur internationally from the united
states outside of the country
without a warrant of any kind without
judicial oversight of any kind without
the approval of a court
and that is exactly the kind of abuse
that led to the enactment of fisa in
1978
that said we want the president to
eavesdrop and engage in surveillance
but only with the oversight of a court
because of all the abuse that is what
this law has
gutted it has given the president vast
new surveillance powers
with no oversight whatsoever mr rifkin
mr greenwald says all conversations can
be listened to in emails is that true
it's not true at all as a matter of fact
what this very modest fix
to fisa does it restores the balance
originally reflected in the 1978 act
1978 act uh devised the system whereby
communications where united states
person is a target
which is primarily in the context of
communications within the united states
but also communications overseas if the
u.s person is a target
are driven by a warrant triggered system
communications involving foreign persons
and these individuals who
do not reside in the united states who
never set foot in the united states
who have no relationship of any kind of
the united states who do not deserve any
constitutional
protections or certainly do not deserve
any statutory protections
that are rooted in our constitutional
values these individuals have always
been surveilled
warrantlessly the way it worked for
decades is
technically prior advent of fiber optics
these communications were intercepted by
nsa
using the satellites over there so if
you had proverbial north korean
general a russian kgb general
or a terrorist sitting in peshawar and
he communicated with another terrorist
or another general
oversees or communicated it's very
important the united states
and the communication was intercepted
overseas those
surveillance intercepts were never ever
driven by warrant
what has changed let's set aside the war
and the fact we need
intelligence far more now than ever
before we change this technology
instead of those conversations taking
place over the air
being intercepted somewhere over ocean
by an nsa satellite
because united states has the best fiber
optic systems
most of those communications flow for
that system so now
all of a sudden and this has really been
a gradual change over the last several
years
these communications are intercepted in
the united states
same expectation of privacy my simple
question to my colleague is this
if conversation bombing proverbial
abdulva terrorists
10 years ago using nsa satellite over
the air calling you in the united states
we intercepted that either warrant
and they were why should be any
different now when the same
conversation flows over the fiber optics
network
and u.s service expectations of privacy
are not the same this is not about u.s
citizens
u.s citizens are not the targets of his
conversations
foreign persons are the problem frankly
for critics let's be honest
i don't know if you're in that category
but a lot of people are debated about it
really do not care if you're foreign or
not
they want to extend the same
constitutional protections the same
expectations of privacy they flow out of
a constitutional compact
to foreigners and they're just nonsense
if you put it this way honestly the
american people you would get a
resounding no
so there's a big question mark here is
it foreign to foreign phone calls
and what we're talking about is a
technical issue that is those phone
calls are routed through u.s
networks or does it also involve
a foreign a call from indianapolis to
london it would not involve call from
indianapolis the way it would work a big
chunk of it is purely foreign to foreign
conversations
by the way i think all of us agree that
it's insane to have a person
in kabul talking to a person in in
baghdad
and have that be driven by warrant but
the instances where again the target of
surveillance
is a foreign person who happens to be
communicating with somebody in the
united states
look it is fundamentally no different
than having a criminal law enforcement
warrant so-called title free warrant
you are mafia don you happen to be
calling your tailor
your tailor is absolutely innocent but
just because you are calling your tailor
to the extent that you have a target of
surveillance as a mafia don that
conversation would not be tuned out
your tailor's expectations of privacy
may be violated
but that's these are the breaks you're
not going to have to go and get a new
warrant if you have the fbi
just because mafia donna is calling the
tailor or or
his groceries can i answer that because
again let me just promote the phones
real quick because
we want to get our viewers involved in
this conversation republicans
202-737-0001 democrats 202-737-0002
independence 202-628-0205 go ahead
what has been going on in this country
for the last six years is that defenders
of
of greater and greater government power
do one of two things to justify
that power number one is they try and
exploit the fear
of americans by ratcheting up the talk
of terrorism and saying that unless you
give the power to the government
you will be killed by terrorists the
second thing they do is they mislead
american people about what has been
going on that's true with iraq it's true
with torture and it's true with the
answer that he just gave about what this
law does
you asked him does this law enable
simply foreign to foreign calls to be
eavesdrop on or
if you're calling from indianapolis to
london can they listen in or if you're
emailing a friend in england can they
read your emails without a warrant
and he basically ignored your question
and said oh it's mostly foreign to
foreign
everybody agrees that foreign to foreign
calls do not need a warrant the
democrats were willing to
to change fisa so that no warrants were
required that is not what this debate is
about
pakistan to afghanistan no warrants what
this law does is say that every
single international communication
emails from indianapolis to london
phone calls from miami to to france
those conversations those emails can now
be listened in
by george bush and the national security
agency with nobody knowing what they're
doing
with no warrant required with no
judicial oversight that is exactly the
situation
that for decades has led to abuses and
it is fundamentally contrary to the
entire system of government
that the founders created which is we do
not trust government leaders
with vast and awesome power to be
exercised in secret
we have a system of checks and balances
and we only trust our government leaders
to eavesdrop on us and to engage in
surveillance with
oversight this law gives vast powers to
listen in our conversations
and read our emails with no connection
to terrorism
with no proof that anyone has ever done
anything wrong and it is an extremely
dangerous situation and it is
vast and and overwhelming let's get a
phone call in here dallas republican
line your first phone call
good morning uh good morning i don't
know whether people are afraid to tell
you the truth
because they can't reveal secrets but
there's a program that was
enacted under clinton that does
everything that we're talking about it's
called echelon
that's open source and that's public so
you guys can talk about that but that's
all we've been talking about this whole
debate the last few years
the question is oh nsa records
every international conversation every
single one and they and they also hear
every domestic call that's that goes
over wires
and wireless they're all recorded
now either the democrats are just
playing partisan games and we're
reinstituting an
old program that dates back to clinton
or
we're now listening to americans
conversations and recording all those
too
y'all can't tell us the truth because
you'd be exposing secrets
the media doesn't know what the heck's
been said in open source so they won't
even tell us about echelon which is an
old program
i i i i don't know whether this is
partisan games
or whether this program has taken vast
new air uh
sweeping intrusions into our public
personal security of american citizens
probably all american international
calls were recorded previously
let's get a response from from both of
our guests is this a reinstatement of an
old law
no and and the reason is even the bush
administration admits
that ever since 1978 when fisa was
enacted it is the only administration
to eavesdrop on the telephone calls of
americans without warrants in violation
of that law but the caller does raise
one critical point which is
what has been going on under the bush
presidency has been has been done
virtually
uh behind a virtually impenetrable wall
of secrecy
james comey was here at the capitol two
months ago and he said
that what he and john ashcroft
discovered in 2004 that the government
was doing
was so patently illegal so
unconscionable that he
and and director mueller of the fbi and
john ashcroft all agree that if this
behavior didn't cease immediately
that they were going to resign from the
bush government in mass
we do not know what those activities are
that prompted such an extraordinary
reaction
on the part of high-level bush lawyers
at the department of justice
we don't know most of what has been
going on in terms of how this government
has been spying on us the congress has
no idea in fact what they just passed in
terms of the power that it gives and i
think the caller is right
most of our government now operates
behind a wall of secrecy and that is an
extraordinary problem for a democracy
skill marketing is not a useful way with
all due respect to wage and debate
almost everything you say with due
respect is untrue as to secrecy
bush administration from the very
beginning after it adopted
uh terrorist surveillance program in
aftermath of september 11 briefed that
program
the versailles gang of eight so members
of congress republican and democrats in
both senate and house intelligence
committees and houses and leaderships
were involved on that that's a fact
there's no dispute about it
we're number one with regard to a new
law as you all know
it brings the fisa court more into
foreign intercepts
than ever before only purely foreign to
foreign conversations i exempt
from judicial review we now have in
place
and again to answer your question very
precisely
in a situation where somebody is calling
from indianapolis let's say
passover pakistan you would not be the
one
target of surveillance your phone number
your voicemail
your email would not trigger any
surveillance regime
if the person you're calling
communicating in is a foreign terrorist
or enrolled in a program for some reason
the surveillance
the call would be caught because of that
but that as i've mentioned i've not
heard you rebut it has always been the
case
in 1979 in 1980 if you had a foreign
individual
calling united states if you look at the
language of fisa and the call was
intercepted overseas because as a matter
of technology that's how it worked
because it was before fiber optics most
calls were transmitted over the air nsa
satellites would have intercepted that
call
without any warrant whatsoever we're
talking about
we should be having a real serious
debate about how to balance
privacy with security not government
security security of american citizens
we're not talking about balancing
privacy versus some alien interest of
somebody from mars
we're talking about our interest in
being alive and it's not a joke
that's not an idol threat we've lost 3
000 americans on september 11
and god forbid we're going to lose a lot
more if we're blind and deaf we should
have a serious debate about it
instead of engaging in scammering to say
that privacy but look let's be honest
there is a privacy interest even in that
kind of foreign intercept
but it's a lot less a lot different
than in the situation where target is an
american person and we should be honest
about distinguishing those two
situations
instead of just repeating like a mantra
privacy interests privacy interests if
it trumps everything
you cannot lead a day in modern society
you cannot live without sacrificing
some privacy in a commercial context in
the context of interacting with your
government we have to be reasonable
about it
we have zero effort at serious debate or
we have slogan hearing
and bashing the bush administration and
that's unfortunate district heights
maryland you're our next phone call
good morning i disagree with this law
completely
we don't know what the bush
administration has been doing they tell
so many
lies can anybody believe anything that
anyone in this administration including
gonzales would say i watch the history
channel a lot and we are
becoming the american third reich
how hitler developed the third right
through fear and intimidation and lies
and this administration is the worst
administrator i'm 70 years
worst administration in my lifetime he
had
george bush had broken every law in this
country he valued the constitution
he violated the privacy of american
citizens he broke an international law
he
did geneva convention he's tortured he
lied and i don't believe the word of
that man's mouth
okay caller we got your point mr rivkin
has the bush administration done an
adequate job
communicating to the american people the
need for programs
like this one eve look it's hard to have
reach soaring heights after chilean
oratory
in in any administration i would say the
bush administration is an
adequate job not a perfect job but not a
bad job communicating with at stake
the difficulty we have is there's
unfortunately such level of partisanship
size level of polarization and size
level immediate hostility
it's just you get drowned out i mean i
don't even know what to tell a caller
who starts from proposition that we live
in uh something resembling a third reich
and bush is not hitler it's hard to have
a serious debate i don't remember i mean
sure there's a lot of us during the
clinton administration but it's not
useful
okay we have vigorous oversight system
with vigorous involvement by congress
and all their issues
we have media that leaks frankly you
know there's
no secret that survives i call it
bureaucratic checks and balances there's
no secret that survives more than
a couple of years in this administration
or any other administration
so any notion that there's a serious
levels of wrongdoing
you know uh irs audits for party island
nixon for partisan advantage or
watergate stuff it's just nonsense
but that's the impression people have
and it provides a difficult context
which have
serious debate mr greenwald your
response
he can say that it's hard to have a
serious debate when a caller says we
don't trust the bush administration but
the fact of the matter is this country
has seen
the bush administration over the last
six years and polls show
overwhelmingly that the american people
do not trust george bush
do not believe that the things he says
is the truth and that begins with the
iraq war and goes forward
and i think what's critical to
acknowledge here is mr rivkin is a
lawyer who
almost always defends the bush
administration i'm a critic of the bush
administration
but look at what the the bush
administration's own lawyers in the
justice department said these are
right-wing lawyers john ashcroft james
comey
they said that the bush administration
in the way they were spying on us
was breaking the law to such an extreme
degree that they were all going to quit
unless it stopped believe them or
believe the only two federal judges in
this country who have opined on what the
administration is doing
who have both concluded emphatically
that the administration was
violating the law fisa is a criminal law
that george bush was breaking the law
and the way that he has been spying on
us over the last four years these are
indisputable facts that that underlie
this entire debate this country does not
trust george bush
and therefore we shouldn't trust any
political leaders to spy on us in secret
and that's the balance that we need we
want them to engage in eavesdropping but
only with judicial oversight
we're talking about the new warrantless
wiretapping law with glenn
greenwald and david rifkin the new
mexico republican line
hello good morning good morning sir uh
i don't understand what a big problem it
is if you're not doing anything wrong or
or you know why is it such a big deal
i mean it's there to protect us not to
hurt us
what's the green one the founders of
this country understood that
if the government is able to break into
our homes anytime they want or
read all of our letters that we
basically would live in a position
of tyranny and they rejected the idea
that the government should be able to
intrude into the lives of people who are
doing nothing wrong
that is the totalitarian image that's
how people
in venezuela live or in saudi arabia or
in egypt where the government listens in
and monitors what you're doing privacy
is a fundamental value in the american
constitutional culture
and it's true that it has to give way
sometimes to concerns about security and
it has given way
greatly but we do not want to be a
society where we simply say to the
government
please know everything that we are doing
read all of our emails listen to all of
our phone calls whether you're doing
something wrong or not
that is a vast power to give to the
government and the proof of that is that
under nixon
and even kennedy and johnson they used
that power against political opponents
they tried to blackmail martin luther
king by invading his personal life and
finding out what he was doing
that is an extraordinary power to want
to give to the government and people who
say
oh let's just turn over to the
government all of our privacy and trust
that they will use it well
are people who are describing a system
of government that is not the united
states
this new law would expire in six months
what does that mean for the capability
of the government to
get up and running and and do some
surveillance on
uh suspected terrorists it's an
unfortunate uh
unfortunate aspect we're gonna have
another debate when congress comes back
the fact that we do not know will be the
regime governing
the intercepts makes it more difficult
you're absolutely right for
uh for the intelligence community to
operate but let me let me be clear again
of all the respecula and it's not useful
to speculate
a posit that we're talking about
interception of all
communications nobody's suggesting that
that is not a serious proposition
and incidentally you can't have it both
ways we have a tyrannical administration
that's marching in lockstep threatening
our liberty or if you look at people
like comey and ash
who by the way ashcroft was pilloried
widely by the left uh
his attorney general engaging in spirit
the fact that we have people engaging in
spirited debate
in the administration they're gone now
they're they're out there
but you have no idea whether a same
debate have occurred i can tell you
i spent nine years in the government in
two administrations and reagan and bush
41
the fact that they have people on the
inside engaging in spirited debate
honest civil servant and public-minded
officials
about some policy issue does not repeat
does not mean it's a horrible wrongdoing
here
and there's angelic being there this is
the bureaucratic checks and balances
that add on to protect our liberty to
of judiciary role congress that is not
the case
where look there are many circumstances
where american citizens
are being searched without any warrant
and the constitution doesn't require
warrant constitution requires a fourth
amendment that searches be reasonable
when you drive
you know when you drive and get stopped
at a sobriety checkpoint
uh around christmas when you come back
from mexico or canada
and you get strip search at the airport
without any warrant when your kid has
his locker searching school
there are many circumstances so-called
special need cases where the government
can reasonably search you and if any
fruits of criminal activity obtained
can prosecute the criminally so the
notion that
frankly glenn that people are
propounding including you that if you
don't have a warrant
but it somehow tyranny is absurd that is
not how things work
kansas city missouri independent line
good morning
kansas kansas city with us hello
you're on the air um yeah i'm
sick of everybody using the the argument
that
uh if i'm not doing something wrong then
why why would it be a problem if the
government is spying on us
but it that's that's how it's about it's
about
the the president's shift to a
tyrannical uh dictatorship um
they the nsa needs to present a
document saying that somebody is doing
something
wrong or they they at least they think
so to a judge
and he needs to confirm this in order to
uh wiretap them otherwise it's illegal
and no no no debate about it it's just
completely illegal
and i i i have nothing more to say about
that i mean
i can't make it any more clear mr rifkin
do you
think that there should be some checks
and balances with this new wiretapping
law
of course we do as a matter of fact we
have more quote-unquote checks and
balances
we now have the large trench of
foreign targets again these are people
who are not americans
they've never come here they can be
north koreans they can be chinese they
can be russians
they can be pakistani et cetera et
cetera when these people
come into contact with united states
they would be instead of
being surveilled against entirely
warrantlessly entirely driven by the
procedures developing the executive
branch
they're going to have a fisa court
review voice procedures
an issue in order either confirming them
or
suggesting they be modified and
eventually gets appealed to the supreme
court
that is the greatest moment by the
courts than ever before but walter
pincus writes in today's washington post
the bush administration plans to leave
oversight of its expanded foreign
eavesdropping program to the same
government officials who
supervise the the surveillance
activities and to the intelligence
personnel who carry them out
but that's of course but that's what
their jobs are if you look at the
original fight cigarette
the attorney general is the key player
you may like or dislike alberto gonzalez
but let's look beyond alberto gonzalez
this is the job for attorney general
mike mcconnell the director of national
intelligence is a highly respected
professional
who would you like to do this job the
secretary of agriculture
i mean secretary of commerce this is
their job you have people signing
affidavits attesting
to the truthfulness of the particular
procedures that are being used to enroll
people in this program you're going to
fisa court review it
i mean the notion that frankly the
caller is suggesting that
you have to have a specific warrant for
everything first of all is
is factually untrue i would suggest to
this person you stop
driving drunk at a sobriety checkpoint
it tries to suppress the evidence
because it was warrantless he's going to
go to jail i
suggest that if his individual returns
home from mexico and is carrying
you know some goods he did not declare
he tries to suppress this evidence he
would lose
in a lawsuit with a treasury department
he doesn't understand how the system
works
the problem individual warrants you
cannot get
warrants fast enough of thousands and
thousands of foreigners
who enrolled in this program and why
would you want to get warrants against
people who are not americans
mr greene let me just address that he
said i think the key here is alberto
gonzalez is the key person and that's
absolutely right and the question that
americans need to answer is
okay we begin with the premise the
president is going to have the power to
eavesdrop on the conversations
of people in order to detect terrorist
pots we all agree on that
now the question is do you want george
bush reading alberto gonzalez
deciding which emails they're reading
through which telephone calls they're
listening to
in complete secrecy with nobody knowing
what they're doing and having to approve
what they're doing
or do you think they ought to only have
a layer of judicial oversight
to make sure that they're really using
those powers those vast and awesome
powers to read our emails
and listen to our telephone
conversations for proper purposes
he he he says mr rifkin says
scaremongering is not something we
should be doing and then you notice
every answer he says this is necessary
because of 911 and don't worry it's only
those foreigners whose calls we're going
to be listening on
that is absolutely false technology now
allows all telephone calls
to be routed through the same switchers
so the government can monitor every
single phone call
that london is making to you in
washington dc to any of the viewers at
home
and they can decide every single one of
these calls involves a u.s citizen
on u.s soil they can listen in on every
single
international call that you make or
receive and every email that you write
and every email that you receive in
complete and total secrecy
and i think americans know the
difference between submitting to a
search
of their shoes before they get in on an
airplane and allowing george bush and
alberto gonzalez to listen to everything
we're saying in writing
with no oversight whatsoever they
understand that i just say 10 seconds
this is you glenn george bush albert
gonzalez do not
choose the targets of surveillance do
not listen to conversations let's be
honest
you have career honorable men and women
at the nsa
who choose the targets of surveillance
using the best judgment
and let's learn what do they report to
who's their boss a report to a director
of
nsa the director of national
intelligence but the notion that you're
trying to vote for the listeners here
it would be george bush sitting in late
at night alberto gonzalez
choosing targets listening conversations
is absurd they do nothing of a kind
neither this attorney general nor any
other attorney general real quick
what are the what are the implications
if they do overstep
the law and that they do uh
listening to conversations of u.s
citizens that are not suspected
terrorists are there is
are there any is there any punishment is
there yes we're talking about people
executing affidavits under the penalty
of perjury
we're talking elaborate reporting to
congress including reporting of any
violations
we're talking about whistleblowers look
this government fundamentally is
incapable
of engaging in the nixonian conduct or
conduct of time of lbj
we have an fdr we're just incapable of
doing it when capable look the worst
thing that has happened so far been
reported
it's some incompetence and some
sloppiness at the fbi regard the
so-called national security letters
there's not been one instance
of any political enemy being audited of
cindy shaheen being surveilled
because we don't know what they've done
and you admit you admit
you admit that this law does not in
order for them to listen in you admit
don't you that this new law does not
require
them to say that the person they're
listening in on has anything to do with
terrorism that requirement has been
eliminated in this new law you admit
that right this
new law only deals with foreign
targets to terrorism can you will you
acknowledge that of course
there's no requirement at all that is
correct you can so you can be an
a drug or armed smuggling north korean
general or an innocent person
yes let's let's let's operate on the
assumption that honorable korea people
at the nsa are so not busy
pursuing real threats that they're
interested in listening to conversation
of innocent foreigners
foreigners by the way you want to listen
conversation with americans you need to
get
a warrant from a fisa court as it's
always been okay we'll leave it there
and go back to phone
calls little rock arkansas republican
line thanks for waiting uh thank you uh
mr rivkin
thank you so much for speaking mr
greenwald thank you so much for speaking
mr riskin every example that you've used
for the uh let's say
you're doing something illegal and you
have the the
authorities have reasonable suspicion to
pull you over you're speaking about a
car
i think what most people are concerned
about and i know what i'm concerned
about is
is you coming into my home you've got no
right coming into my
home unless a judge deems it necessary
i i think it is constitutional that you
you don't have the right to seize
and to search illegally and i do think
that this is
i mean well it's a law now but i do
think that this is illegal and
unconstitutional i think that
you need to go through a judge you need
that checking the check and balance
which has always been
the way that we've done it um i think it
was benjamin franklin who said that the
man that
would give up essential freedom deserves
first
for security deserves neither freedom
nor security
and i agree with that totally you've got
no right coming into my home
unless a judge thinks that it's
necessary
a couple of things hopefully to reassure
you first of all we are
talking about judicial involvement in
this effort i've
said it now four times the only
difference is that instead of having a
specific warrant
you would have the fisa court the very
same judges
eventually may well be appealed to the
supreme court approving
the particular structure the particular
rules so it would not be done on the say
so of alberto gonzalez or mike mcconnell
point number one point number two
nobody's talking about coming to your
house
we're talking about situations where the
target of surveillance is a foreigner
who happens to come into some contact
with the united states
in a form of a phone call but let me
just pause it to you a very simple
proposition i don't know how how you
feel about your privacy
if i am pulled out of my car and told to
walk you know
the yellow line and touch my nose or if
i'm strip search crossing the border
i think that is a far more fundamental
intrusion of my privacy
than somebody intercepting a phone call
where i may be a secondary player
i just don't understand the argument
that it is or if my kid in
high school gets his locker searched or
gets strip searched and those things
have been upheld
but any warrant about by the way any
reasonable you know these word
reasonable suspicions there's a question
of reasonable suspicion there's no need
for particularized suspicion
these types of searches have been upheld
because the government has a general
interest in preventing certain bad
things from happening
i don't understand why is it palatable
to be strip searched when you
when you cross back in in the united
states but it's not palatable to have
your
phone call intercepted we're talking
with glenn greenwald
he's a former constitutional lawyer and
a contributing writer to salon.com
and also the author of this book a
tragic legacy how a good versus evil
mentality destroyed the bush presidency
and our other guest is david ricken
former justice department official with
the reagan administration how many years
did you spend in the government
nine years reagan two and uh and uh well
reagan won reagan two and bush 41. did
you deal solely with these issues that
we're talking about
a lot with national security issues let
me also tell you i have seen
people remarkable talent in the
government i've seen people who are less
talented i've never seen any sinister
individual that sort of fits in this
caricature of people just dying
you know the best government officials
cared about doing public good the worst
care about their pension and
working very hard i've never seen any
sinister figure trying to
you know invade our civil liberty for
cakes they're just it's just not
real can i just stress that briefly uh
in the reagan administration of course
there were numerous high officials who
were convicted of
of crimes for for violating the law but
but beyond the reagan administration you
know mr erickson is saying oh don't
worry these are nsa professionals they
won't do anything wrong if you let them
eavesdrop on us in secret
we have a law in place in 1978 fisa
which resulted because
once the the abuses of the nixon
administration became known
congress investigated how these
eavesdropping powers were being used and
every administration truman eisenhower
kennedy johnson and then culminating
with richard nixon
abuse these powers for improper means
that is what government officials do
when you give them power that is what
the founding fathers recognize we do not
trust political leaders in the united
states to exercise vast powers without
checks because
every time they will abuse it and that
is what history proves
cocoa florida republican line
tomorrow i i it's not coming
in the home it's it's going out of the
home for one thing they're not coming
into your home you're putting stuff
out of the home and this new bill was
passed by
democrats but they don't want illegal
aliens to be caught for
stuff paid for i have a question for
both gentlemen first the one on the left
if this is an illegal thing done by
president bush
the ten uh congressmen and senators
including senator
daschle uh senator harry reid and nancy
pelosi
aren't they co-conspirators and for mr
ripken
uh just like i said no they want to
control the airwaves for radio
but when it comes to catching terrorism
coming out of homes or going into homes
from abroad
they want that to be stopped i've never
made a phone call overseas
and i've never got one in except for
business probably
so i i don't understand it thank you
go ahead mr green well the idea that
they've consulted with democrats jay
rockefeller has made clear assets tom
daschle and many others
that they were told the broadest
sketches of what it was the government
was doing
and they demanded more information
information that dick cheney
ignored but the fact that democrats were
told that george bush was breaking the
law
and they didn't act aggressively enough
doesn't change the fact that the
behavior
was illegal and again i don't want
anyone to take my word for it
again the two judges who have looked at
this conduct have said it was illegal
and and i would ask mr rifkin why it
wasn't that james comey and john
ashcroft and the department of justice
said
oh well there's a little disagreement
here that we have they told george bush
what you're doing
is breaking the law he ordered it to
continue anyway and that's when they
said
if you continue to do this what you've
been doing for the last three years we
are all going to quit
in mass and only then did he stop
because it was months before the
election and couldn't
abide a scandal that way so i think we
ought to look at what
the bush doj lawyers have said and what
the federal courts have said
and they have said that george bush has
broken the law repeatedly and how he has
spied on us
we don't have time to get into this but
without respect on your painting
of a broad brush we had the terror
surveillance program
that came into existence shortly after
september 11.
it continued in 2001 2002 2003 2004
it was re-authorized every 45 days by
the officials at the justice department
including office of legal counsel and
approved by attorney general
one john ashcroft for whatever reason
i've actually written speculating that
one might have happened one particular
aspect of his
program then you had a new head of
office of legal counsel who came in
who took the position that differed a
bit in one respect
from the previous head a spirited debate
ensued
the way it works it's supposed to work i
would be if i were you reassured by that
okay that people within this
administration as any other
administrations debate those issues they
worked it out
there was no there's no illegality prior
but they all got replaced because
i think we've adequately addressed this
aspect of the of the debate washington
democrats line you're next
washington hi go ahead my name is
cassandra richardson i was
kind of hostile but i'm going to try and
calm myself down right now
and i noticed that the brothers are are
there
we all are brothers and sisters no
matter what color you are
and now my question is with the
authorities interception and you're
saying that
as president bush fought will the
amendment
uh i say title 18
section 20 251 or 25-16
will that be changed relating to mail
fraud that's my question
can either of you address that i don't
think that statute is in
play here i think they're the only
statute being changed is fisa
and what is required in terms of
warrants jupiter florida republican line
how do you do a little nervous first
time calling in
but let me say first of all i respect
the office of the presidency
i'm not interested in a coup or any
stripping all the offices or their
powers but let me say this
no one is going to listen to my
telephone call
no one is going to read my email or
anyone that i know
but if we had been on top of this
and we had listened to muhammad atta
then we would oops caller sorry about
that that was my fault
college station texas you're next okay
thank you
go ahead hello you're on the air sir
am i on you know we're going to put you
on hold and move on to chicago sorry
about that that was my fault
chicago you're on here good morning how
are you
doing well sir uh my question is this to
to both the gentleman
i'm calling on my cell phone this
morning and
with the wireless technology that we
have
do i have any expectation of privacy
because there could be a 16 year old
high school kid across the street from
me
monitoring my telephone calls you know
right now
so what expectation of privacy do i have
in a wireless society
i'll hang up and listen to your answers
thank you mr greenwald
i'm sorry not not much and frankly this
is one of the things that puzzles me
we as again as a as a price of living in
a modern society where you value the
convenience of using a mobile phone
which can be easily intercepted by any
warrant and not even by the government
where we submit reams of data to be able
to get easy credit
where that data gets shared around we
somehow accept all of this
well except for some people who really
want to be you know
reclusive but yet when it comes to
dealing with a government
our government not a repressive
government the people we elect somehow
we
use entirely different standards we want
to erect walls
and then what we call a couple of calls
ago trying to make i think a very
important point
we pay a huge price for erecting these
barriers
for there's a price i'm not saying that
we shouldn't pay this price
yes there are checks and balances glenn
but don't you agree that for every check
and balance it doesn't come free
it's it you the government is efficiency
is reduced
it's more difficult to remember the
famous connecting the dots it's more
difficult to connect the dots
we have to understand that there's
countervailing imperatives here that
have to be balanced properly it's not
all
gee let's put as many restrictions on
the government of a point would be
completely ineffectual
and you know i agree and i began this
discussion by making as explicitly clear
as i could
that everybody agrees that we want the
government eavesdropping on terrorists
that is the premise
of what we are doing and then the
question becomes what safeguards are
necessary the caller referred earlier to
oh if only we had been listening on
muhammad ada prior to september 11th
george bush had the power and the
authority
to listen in on any suspected terrorist
under the
under the fisa law we all want that and
he had that power
the fact that the government didn't
listen in on mohamed ada is not because
george bush didn't have the power
he did it's because he didn't exercise
that power
and i agree we need balance and that is
the law that the balance is of the
balance that fisa struck which is
yes we want our government to be able to
eavesdrop for proper purposes
but knowing that for decades that power
has been abused we will only allow our
political leaders to listen in on us
once they convince a judge in advance
that we've actually done something wrong
or there's reason to think that we've
done something wrong
and therefore we should have our
conversations listening that is the
process
that this law ten second con connection
very important
glenn it's not true the 911 commission
makes it very clear
that the fbi felt under the existing
rules they could not search muhammad on
a computer
we had even a fbi whistleblower he came
and testified if we get a name
rally and that's not true well again
there's reasonable belief that the
government would not have because the
fisa court was very restrictive
in how they approved that they never
reject any warrants the fisa corp is
they
reject forgive me they reject plenty of
warrants informally
and well okay we'll leave it there
here's an email question for both of you
from kathleen in athens ohio does this
recent expansion she
gives it to you first but we'll let both
of you answer it does this recent
expansion of the fisa legislation
retroactively exempt
any of the allegedly illegal wiretapping
that has already taken place during the
last six years
what the what the statute does is it is
it says that
the phone companies are required
to comply with any orders the president
gives to turnover data although they
have a process where they can object
and that when if they comply with what
the president orders in terms of giving
our data or access they cannot be sued
there will be no liability
what the law doesn't do is say that for
everyone who has broken the law over the
last six years
they will be immune but the president
said
and and mike mcconnell has said once
congress comes back from the recess the
first thing we want them to do
is to give retroactive liability to all
of the people
and the phone companies and and the
telecom industries who have been
breaking the law for the last six years
we want you to give them immunity not
only from being sued
but from being criminally prosecuted
that is next on their agenda the
president has said so
and what that would essentially mean is
that not only the president but also
telecom companies who have been turning
over our data illegally to the
administration
will have no accountability for breaking
our laws that is an extraordinarily
dangerous step
uh do you agree that well i agree with
this legislation does not provide
rhetoric of immunity what i find utterly
depressing
is every situation and by the way you
mentioned several times about two
district court judges
of an appellate court that threw out
this lawsuit we have
depressing to me i wrote about it
several months ago in wall street
journal look at the situation we had in
world war ii
where the government industry came
together to meet a common threat what do
we have now
you may hate george bush you may
disagree everything is dumb but surely
you're not alleging that foreign
phone companies in complying with orders
administrative orders issued by the
government the last several years
did anything willfully wrong but they
were interested in
in violating your privacy they did what
their government told them to do
people who sued those companies who are
trying to impede every ability
of phone companies and every other
company in america to cooperate with the
government
as an asian and terrorist it's
despicable to me the fact that the
government has to spend time and
resources to go and try to add
retroactive liability is depressing
we're absolutely distorting the
incentive structure
but the ceo of a company several years
from now would find it safe for glenn
not to cooperate with a government and
have a number nine alumni come and
cooperate
that is to me absolutely sickening let's
get
let's get a couple more phone calls in
here before we have to go college
station texas good morning
uh good morning um can i beg your
indulgence
to make a complicated point here can you
do it quickly caller we're running out
of time
well i've been waiting for a while um
the man on the right has no veracity at
all
let's talk about what we know we know
that alberto gonzalez
has hired people who were inferior uh
who were not not the best qualified
people
so they have perverted the civil service
system uh we should have the best people
doing these jobs if they contract jobs
out like wiretapping
like they've done in iraq to third
parties there's no way to supervise
these people
there's no way to know what they do who
they wiretap on
and they don't keep records so let the
man on the right says is preposterous
uh he he has no legitimacy and
just trust this stuff americans are
smarter than that
and the majority of the american people
know better and we do not want to have
this kind of uh fiasco typical
wiretapping program
that occurred in iraq okay caller we've
we've already talked about those issues
our last phone call bloomington illinois
republican line
uh good morning i have been listening
with interest to mr revkin and mr
greenwald and
i have heard mr rivkin speak on several
prior occasions and
mr greenwald on one or two as well i
believe i've also read
the scholarly articles authored and
co-authored by mr rivkin
several of them in recent months and in
the last year or so including the wall
street journal
article to which he just alluded i think
the
debate here this morning has been won
hands down by mr rivkin he's been very
specific
as a lawyer practicing almost four
decades i i think he's very scholarly on
the point
and he's accurate and i think the
mischaracterizations by mr greenwald
are typical of those of the democratic
party
and of the liberals concerning the
provisions of the patriot act
and of the military commissions act of
2006
bloomington let me ask you to get a
little bit specific what were some of
the mischaracterizations so we can get a
response
in the patriot act no by mr greenwald
with regard to the uh he's painting
with a broad brush uh his
description of the provisions of this
new law
which were passed by a congress composed
of republicans as well as democrats
it's unfortunate that it was extended
for only six months
rather than the three months that some
of the democrats wish it to be extended
it will be extended again i'm confident
in six months
we'll go through the same debate again
and we'll get the same result
we have to have some protections for the
citizens of the united states
and to try to extend all of those
protections to
foreigners who have no constitutional
rights is folly
let's let's talk a little bit about the
six-month issue six months from now
if they bring this back up is it going
to be more politically difficult
for democrats to not agree to to give
another six months or a permanent
extension of this fisa law well i think
it's interesting a
mr rifkin mentioned earlier oh it's
unfortunate that in six months we're
going to have to have another debate
that was his
his verbatim quote and i think it's in
incre incredibly important to point out
that what happened here is congress has
been attempting to revise fisa to fix
whatever problems there were democrats
in congress were
for several years and the bush
administration was insisting oh no we
don't need any changes
to fisa we don't want any changes to
fisa suddenly weeks ago
they suddenly declared oh we need fires
are revised dramatically within a matter
of weeks otherwise there'll be a
terrorist
attack and it will be your fault and the
law that was passed was passed in an
extraordinary rush
no hearings were held it's a complicated
law there's disagreement among good
people in good faith about what the law
even means the people in congress who
just passed this law
under a lot of pressure and and all
kinds of rhetoric from the
administration
have no idea what it is that they just
enacted and
and it's the only saving grace of this
law is that now
in a period of deliberation we can have
hearings and we can have a genuine
debate
about what kind of eavesdropping powers
we want to vest in
in not just this president but future
presidents as well that is the debate
that we did not have
because congress at george bush's
direction passed this
frenetically with barely an
understanding of what they were doing
that's
going to a short responsibility very
short several points first of all
i really hope as we have another debate
we can get beyond
any alleged sins by this administration
this administration is going to be in
power for less than two years
we're supposed to look to the long term
so to me everything about george bush
lumber and gonzales is almost relevant
point number one point number two
yes there would be some reauthorization
beyond six months be pretty awkward for
the democrats
in the absence of evidence that some
horrible things have occurred during the
next six months and they won't
to say we were for it six months ago but
not anymore
and and glenn i would welcome a debate i
wish we had a real
serious debate that would acknowledge
there's a difference between american
and foreigners
but the difference in this set of
expectations of privacy and our
expectation of privacy
would acknowledge that i frankly have
not heard you acknowledge that
the proposition we all want to listen to
terrorists is not entirely true
yes you want to listen to terrorists but
there's a price to be paid the more
restrictions you put on the government's
ability to listen to terrorists
but less would be your intelligence take
that's the truth
there should be no restrictions on the
government's ability to listen in on
terrorist only to do so in secret i
think that's the point
okay we'll have to leave it there glenn
greenwald david rifkin good debate this
morning thank you for being with us
we're going to take a short break and
talk to amy walters here editor-in-chief
of hotline